let's talk about slime mold uh
specifically i want to talk about a uh a
bag of goo called physarum polycephalum
basically it's
snot with a bunch of nuclei in it um
it's it's gross and
it doesn't have a brain that's the
important part here ficerum is weird the
way it eats is it
extends little tendrils of protoplasm in
kind of a wave front looking for food
and when it finds the food it draws back
all of the tendrils that haven't found
food and makes a more sort of focused
pathway to the food that it has found
now what that means in practice is that
you can use viscera in a lab to solve
network problems
what do i mean well you can have it
solve a maze you can put the vicerum at
the entrance of the maze you can put the
food at the exit and then the
slime mold spreads throughout the whole
maze and then wherever the part is that
actually is the solution that gets from
the entrance to the exit
that's the only protoplasmic tendril it
leaves
you can
make it replicate the kind of highways
and railroads that people build so in a
couple of really interesting experiments
some researchers in japan for example
drew a map and they put food where all
the japanese cities are they use oat
flakes and then they put the fisherum
down in what would be tokyo and they let
it spread out and depending on the
conditions that you set up so it'll
build a network among all of these
different cities right that are made of
food
if you use uh bright light to replicate
the topographic features that uh that a
rail line wouldn't be able to get over
like
a lake let's say or a mountain because
five serum doesn't like to grow in
bright light then what you end up with
is something that looks a lot like the
japanese rail network and depending on
how you do it and which experiment you
run it's actually more efficient than
the japanese rail network and other
scientists have done similar experiments
so they've done one that looks a lot
like the highway system in the uk and
then the one that i really like is
researchers took a globe
and they spun it and covered it with hot
agar that's the growth medium that the
stuff lives in
then they cut away the oceans leaving
just the continents and then put the oat
flakes the food where the asian cities
would have been
about a thousand years ago let the fight
serum start growing from what's now
beijing and it ends up looking a lot
like the silk road
so uh
what does that mean well in a paper
that's just coming out uh the stuff
actually solves a classic artificial
intelligence trap
it's the kind of thing they used to
train robots for where it'll get around
a trap
looking for food and the way it does
that is that it avoids its own trail
when it spreads out it leaves this vile
like sugary stuff kind of like a snail
does but made of different things and
the ficerum knows that if there's that
trail left that's the space that it's
already been in so it avoids that which
the researchers say
is a kind of externalized spatial memory
now
what does that mean well a lot of the
researchers who are doing these studies
kind of hinted the idea in the
discussion sections of their papers that
there's maybe a unified field theory of
planning somewhere hidden in this that
if human beings plan roads and highways
in the same way that a uh that a slime
old might build them if you could give a
slime all the chance to do it that maybe
there's some kind of uh math out there
that would tell us how to build you know
the new high-speed rail system they're
building california or a way to get
through an office more efficiently if
you just had raw space
so that's fascinating and i like the
idea that maybe you can solve these kind
of small scale problems but what's more
interesting to me is the idea that the
slime mold like some other animals out
there
is solving
problems the way something with
intelligence would but
a slimy as i said at the top doesn't
have a brain
so how can it be intelligent well
obviously there's a problem with the way
we're defining intelligence right i mean
ant colonies similarly have externalized
spatial intelligence so an individual
ant might not be so smart but the whole
colony is uh octopuses play jokes on
their keepers and aquariums crows and
ravens lie to each other about where
they've hidden food
well octopuses don't have a nervous
system the way we understand it they're
not mammals crows and ravens don't have
forebrain so how do they lie
this interests me not so much because
we're probably not defining intelligence
the right way on earth although it does
kind of seem that way but
i'm going to go sci-fi on you for a
second
it really worries me for when we get to
another planet and we're looking for
aliens
because how are we going to know if
they're smart or not it's not going to
be like star trek we're not going to see
people who look just like us with weird
foreheads right we're going to get to
another planet and it's going to be
covered in highways made of protoplasmic
ooze they're going to be multi-tentacled
things doing what to eat each of them
seems like stand-up comedy
and we're not going to notice